Speaker 1: So as we continue to head to the 2022
midterm elections, we are now under a year away
from those midterm elections, I was talking
to our YouTube rep yesterday and he feels and
I agree that the 20 to 22 midterm season
is sort of going to get going in earnest,
probably in mid to late March or early April this
year. It's going to be quite wild, and I don't
know that it's going to be particularly good for
Democrats. There's a real possibility I won't say
a probability, but there's a real possibility that
Republicans take the House and the Senate and many
governorships in November, next November under
a year from now. And one of the things that
I want to let you know is that the four year
nightmare of Trump has really changed aspects of
our politics in a way that goes beyond Trump to
the degree that Trump is no longer a candidate.
But his presidency impacts the people that
are candidates. As an example of that,
I present to you the reality that many 2022
Republican candidates have been accused of
assaulting or threatening to murder people,
and that in times past, it would be far less
likely that these individuals would continue to be
viable candidates for office. But they are today,
and I believe to some degree, this is thanks
to the coarsening of the discourse and the.
Absolutely absurd way in which Donald Trump's
candidacy and ultimately presidency has.
Diminished any serious minimum standard for
behavior from candidates for public office,
so very good article in Slate about
this. Ben Mathis Lily writes about it
and says things might be different by
November of 22. But as it stands right now,
Republicans are in a good position to retake
Congress. I agree. The incumbent Democratic
president's approval rating is low. Off-Year
elections in swing states are tilting red.
Rising costs are forcing certain bloggers himself
included who don't enjoy macroeconomics, not just
to pay more for groceries, but to read articles
about economics. The key phrase is conventional
indicators, and he points out that things are
a lot different in this kind of Trump era,
pointing out that in recent days, a right wing
Pennsylvania activist and former army ranger
Sean Parnell, who was endorsed by Trump in the
state's 2022 Senate primary two months ago,
is now involved in an ongoing trial in which
Parnell's ex-wife testified that he once strangled
her and has hit their children. In 2019, Parnell
made an appearance on a Fox Nation talk show
in which he blamed feminism for creating quote
women tyrants and asserted men don't want to put
up with the B.S. of high maintenance, narcissistic
women. He has denied allegations of abuse. Similar
accusations have been made against three other
candidates in potentially competitive 2022 races,
either endorsed by Trump or whoever shot a
good chance at earning his support in Georgia.
Trump has endorsed the Senate campaign of former
football player Herschel Walker. Walker's ex-wife
and one of his ex-girlfriends have both accused
him of threatening to kill them to kill them. His
ex-wife, who received a protective order against
him, said he once pointed a gun at her. Walker
denies the ex-girlfriend's accusation and says
he doesn't remember threatening his now ex-wife.
We then go to Ohio's 16th district, currently
represented by Republican Anthony Gonzalez,
who is not running for reelection. Trump has
endorsed a one time aide of his named Max Miller,
former White House press secretary Stephanie
Grisham says Miller pushed her against the wall
and slapped her while they were dating during
Trump's presidency. Miller denies it. Per The
Washington Post, Miller also pleaded no contest to
two misdemeanor charges related to an alleged 2007
assault. The charges were later dismissed as part
of a program for first time offenders and guilty
to a disorderly conduct charge related to a fight
outside a bar. OK, so there's Max Miller moving on
in Missouri. Former Gov. Eric Greitens is running
for Senate has appeared with Rudy Giuliani, hired
Donald Trump Jr's girlfriend, Kimberly Guilfoyle,
as the national chair of his campaign. Greitens
resigned as governor in 2018 after a woman
who was not his wife said he had slapped her,
intimidated her into performing oral sex on
him and taken a nude photo of her without
permission. That he told her he would release
if she spoke about their affair he denies it
says the affair was consensual. However, an
investigative committee of state legislators
found the woman's version of events credible.
This is I don't want to say that prior to Trump.
These folks definitely would have had their
campaigns ended by allegations. And remember,
allegations are allegations. In some of
these cases, they've been investigated and
found credible. In other cases, we have
denials, et cetera. But prior to Trump,
many of these folks would never think to even run
because of the disadvantage that the allegations
would have. Now that Trump has proven proven
that it really doesn't matter to about half of
the voters in this country, what you're accused
of are, in some cases, even what you admit to.
The floodgates have been completely and totally
opened to any kind of character, no matter how
unsuited to public office, no matter how vile
the allegations against them. This is an example
of a change that may be permanent. That may be
permanent thanks to the coarsening of discourse
and American politics. Thanks to Donald Trump
and Trumpism, we will see how these people do